this is Stuart Kimball reading for
Jordan remain though Mario and Rabbids
Sparks of Hope Builds on the core idea
of its predecessor Kingdom battle its
formula makes some big departures too
most notably Sparks of Hope outright
transforms the flow of combat dropping
the grid-based movement and strict
action economy of Kingdom battle to
incorporate a wider variety of
meaningful choices that you can make for
each character on their turn the result
is a combat experience that feels akin
to what you might find in a tabletop
role-playing game like Dungeons and
Dragons where movement economy all
available movements an action economy
every possible action influence one
another taking place after the events of
Kingdom battle Sparks of Hope sees Mario
Luigi Princess Peach bipo and their new
rabid friends banding together to defeat
a mysterious monster known only as cursa
to do so they'll have to partner up with
various Sparks a fusion of Lumas and
Rabbids and travel to a variety of
planets throughout the Galaxy where
they'll run into and also team up with
rabid Rosalina Bowser and a mysterious
rabbit that only goes by Edge like its
predecessor Sparks of Hope is a
turn-based strategy Adventure game where
the heroes and villains take turns
moving through a self-contained stage
and shooting at each other I got the
chance to play a good three hours of
Sparks of Hope at a preview event which
included the game's prologue first world
and a later World part way through the
game I really enjoyed my time with
Sparks of Hope the far more cinematic
direction of the plot and further
personalization of the Rabbids injects a
lot of fun charm into the story I'm
especially fond of rabid Peach whose
voice actor does a marvelous job of
Dripping hilariously stereotypical mean
girl energy into every line
literally but the eternally mopey and
lazy rabid Rosalina is also amusing
beepo is a bit annoying and based on
their know-it-all personality I think
that's exactly what Ubisoft Milan and
Ubisoft Paris are going for but
otherwise I really like all the
characters that go around but it was the
gameplay that really stood out to me
which empathizes the importance of
movement in tactical combat in most
cases turn-based strategy games separate
the movement economy and the action
economy every character has a collection
of actions they can take as well as a
limited amount of movement per turn and
while one economy can affect the other
like a character moving towards an enemy
to get them in range for an attack the
two generally do not mix when they do
mix it's almost always in the form of an
action-complementing Movement Like an
attack that moves a character closer to
their target or an ability that makes a
character invisible however it's rarer
for these type of games to have movement
influence the action economy allowing
you to take special actions by moving
this results in a lot of tactical
turn-based games where movement is the
most boring part of combat as it's just
how you go from point A to point B when
I spoke to Mario plus Rabbids Sparks of
Hope associate producer Quentin caregi
he told me that the development team got
a lot of positive feedback in regards to
Kingdom battle's movement economy and so
when it came time to make a sequel the
team decided to double down and further
build upon it Sparks of Hope ditch's
grid-based movement creating more
opportunities to use your movement in
creative ways on their turn all
characters can move use pipes leap off
allies to hover to another spot Dash
through an enemy to damage and trip them
up parkour over Low cover and hide
behind cover several characters have
unique movement actions too Mario for
instance can either enter a slow-mo
bullet time while in midair to snipe two
Targets with his twin pistols an edge
can be upgraded so that she can perform
three dashes in a sync movement plus
rescued Sparks can be equipped to your
characters unlocking even more abilities
for your characters on top of what they
can already do and since there's no
order of operations to the action
economy you have a surprising amount of
agency every turn and how and when you
use your movement you can if you want
move to dash through an enemy use an
item and then move again to jump off an
ally and hover to a new spot and then
finally attack and you can switch up who
you're directing at any point
compounding the sheer possibility of
strategies you can achieve in a single
turn of combat you don't have complete
Freedom as there are a few limitations
within this framework that you'll have
to consider first off even if every
character can take any of their actions
that they want and do in whatever order
they want they're limited to only two
actions per turn and second once a
character takes their action they can no
longer use any of their movement a
character can still use their full
movement economy after using an item
their special technique or one of their
two spark abilities though as craigie
explains it the second rule is to ensure
that players still prioritize reaching
cover as part of the Tactical experience
of combat originally the game didn't
have that second consideration allowing
players to easily direct their
characters out of cover to attack
enemies and then Retreat back to cover
in the same turn unintentionally
transforming strong close range Fighters
like the shotgun wielding Peach and
combat Gauntlet toting rabid Mario into
devastating hit and run Specialists I
like the this new structure as it
encourages you to pay more attention to
what sort of movement options you have
first that's where the real-time
elements really come into play as many
allow you to use your movement to attack
enemies dashing through a ball bomb will
ignite its fuse for example giving you
precious little time to pick it up and
throw it before it explodes it's a risky
maneuver but one that gives you a whole
extra area of effect attack some stages
have elemental hazards as well like fans
that will intermittently turn on and
blow any unprotected creatures off the
map into Oblivion in those cases your
movement is tied to both your survival
and that of your enemy you need to be
wary of the fans on your turn and
conscious of how you can move about the
map to get the fans to blow away your
opponent the greater movement economy
isn't the only big change in Sparks of
Hope the game also kicks off with you
having a wider option of characters to
choose from Kingdom battle sees you
begin with only Mario rabid Peach and
rabid Luigi with more characters joining
your party throughout the story but in
Sparks of hope you can form your party
of playable characters from the initial
pool of six Mario Luigi Peach rabid
Mario rabid Luigi and rabid Peach and
you unlock a seventh option Edge after
completing both the prologue and first
area you just have a lot more Choice
early on it's a lot to keep track of and
experiment with but man it all results
in an incredibly fun game that I cannot
wait to play in full every battle felt
like an opportunity to switch things up
and try something new in order to
further refine how to get most out of my
movement in each character's unique
skill set even after the whole three
hours I had I still left the preview
event thinking about how I hadn't gotten
the chance to try absolutely every
combination possible Sparks of Hope is
definitely a game to look out for coming
to switch on October 20th